investigators are trying to learn why an
Amtrak train full of Republican members
of Congress hit a garbage truck killing
a passenger in the truck lawmakers
including some doctors rushed off the
train to help the injured the accident
happened in Crozet Virginia that's just
over 100 miles southwest of Washington
the lawmakers were going to White
Sulphur Springs West Virginia for a
conference Nancy Cordes is there Nancy
good morning good morning the show must
go on GOP lawmakers are meeting with the
president today they'll also sit down
with the secretaries of state and
defense the one congressman who was
hospitalized has now been released but
an aide to House Speaker Paul Ryan is
still being treated a jarring start to
this long-planned
annual retreat I know it's been a
harrowing day vice president pence
tried to reassure rattled lawmakers
after tragedy struck halfway through a
five hour train ride hundreds of members
their families and aides were passing
through tiny Crozet Virginia when their
chartered train struck a dump truck
shearing it into boom jarring type of
post sound and feeling strange home
almost like an explosion lawmakers some
of them doctors rushed off the train to
tend to the wounded in one picture you
can see representative Brad Wenstrup a
former combat surgeon carrying a
stretcher with Senators Cassidy and
flake members tried to save 28-year old
Christopher Foley a passenger on the
truck we attempted to resuscitate him
but I don't think for his family that he
suffered Kansas congressman Roger
Marshall tended to another passenger we
were able to keep appalled skip because
a decent airway NTSB investigators now
on scene say it's unclear why the truck
was in the trains path we also consider
distraction as a potential factor the
lawmakers completed their journey by bus
as they try to get back to work
the House chaplain was on the train as
well so there was the ability to
administer last rites at all in all it
was a pretty tough day
strangely enough Senate Democrats
experienced a similar tragedy on the way
to their retreat in West Virginia last
year a four vehicle accident on the
highway that turned one car into a
fireball a fatal accident directly in
front of their bus Norah Nancy thank you
so much